[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver dans ce nouveau numéro de
Parlement hebdo pour revivre les temps
forts de la semaine au Parlement et nous
accueillons cette semaine Sylvain
Maillard bonjour bonjour député de Paris
et président du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée national beaucoup d'actu
pour vous à revoir et le moment fort de
cette semaine au Parlement c'est bien
sûr la déclaration de politique général
du nouveau Premier ministre Gabriel
hatthal mardi devant les députés il a
annoncé toute une série de mesures pour
rétablir rétablir l'ordre l'autorité
dans le pays et conserver notre
souveraineté un discours qui sans
surprise n'a pas convaincu les
parlementaires de gauche il dénonce la
politique trop marqué à droite du
gouvernement et Gabriel hatal n'a pas
non plus convaincu les républicains dont
il a besoin pour faire passer ses textes
au Parlement et le texte important à
faire adopter en ce début d'année c'est
l'inscription de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans dans la
Constitution première étape franchie
cette semaine avec le vote favorable des
députés la balle est désormais dans le
camp du Sénat où l'issue des débats est
inctaine le plus jeune premier ministre
de la 5e République a donc fait sa
déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale ce moment
incontournable et l'occasion pour un
premier ministre d'exposer les objectifs
du gouvernement et de fixer le cap
voyons les quelques lignes claires fixé
par dans cette DPG avec Elsa
mondingava
pendant 1h 200 le Premier ministre a
dévoilé sa feuille de route madame la
Présidente parler au français c'est au
fond entendre 4 appel à l'action pour le
travail pour qu'il paye mieux et
toujours plus que l'inactivité partout
et pour tous pour nos services publics
pour qu'il soit accessible et de qualité
partout et pour tous pour l'autorité le
civisme le respect des droits et devoirs
partout et pour tous pour un
environnement plus respirable partout et
pour
tousab ond aux inquiétudes de la France
qui doute et notamment la France des
classes moyennes je veux m'adresser à
tous ces Français souvent de la classe
moyenne toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont souvent le sentiment de
subir à ces Français qui ont le
sentiment d'avoir tous les devoirs quand
d'autres ont tous les droits à ces
Français qui ne demandent pas la lune
mais simplement à pouvoir vivre de leur
travail éduquer leurs enfants se soigner
et vivre en sécurité le plus jeune
premier ministre de 5e République mise
également sur l'autorité avec des
formules aux accents sarkozistes tu
casses tu répares tu s tu nettoies tu
défies l'autorité on t'apprend à la
respecter il déroule le programme
législatif des prochains mois loi sur la
fonction publique texte sur la justice
des mineurs aide active à mourir mais le
gouvernement veut aussi faire passer des
réformes par voie réglementaire ce sera
le cas pour l'ame l'aide médicale d'État
dev Sylvain Mayard voilà pour les lignes
de force de ce de ce discours d'unh20
alors Gabriel hatal a fait beaucoup
d'annonces mais il veut désmicardiser
débureaucratiser déverrouiller la France
est-ce que ce volontarisme à tous les
étages ne vous rappelle pas à quelqu'un
finalement c'était quand même un
discours assez à droite euh Nicolas
Sarkozi n'aurait pas dit mieux en tout
cas ce que j'entends c'est la réponse à
ce que nous entendons nous partout dans
nos circonscriptions faire en sorte de
libérer protéger n la valeur travail
c'est ce que nous avons toujours porté
au fond le Premier ministre euh dans un
souffle que je veux saluer c'est vrai
que c'était une déclaration de politique
générale ceux qui ont pu la suivre je
crois on céit un moment assez fort avec
un discours puissant pour faire en sorte
que les politiques publique que nous
portons s'incarne dans dans le quotidien
nous c'est ce qu'on nous dit en
permanence vous votez des lois ça ne
s'incarne pas suffisamment dans le
quotidien ça ne change pas suffisamment
notre ctien c'est un peu débloquer le
système c'est ça oui je je je je on on
sent un empêchement euh dans la crise
agricole que que nous vivons cette cette
semaine que nous avons vécu déjà depuis
quelques jours montre bien ça ce côté la
bureaucratie nous nous opprime nous
empêche de faire notre travail mais ça
on le sent partout partout partout sur
le logement même chose je vois
régulièrement des maères qui me disent
je ne construis pas pour des raisons
parce que pour plein de raisons
différentes mais à chaque fois il y a
toujours un empêchement parce qu'il y a
des recours en permanence parce que
c'est compliqué parce que ça va ça va me
prendre un
fou et qu'au fond il y a toujours des
bonnes raisons pour pas faire et donc il
ne faut pas la la l'administration doit
être là pour aider elle doit pas être là
pour empêcher et c'est ce qu'a voulu
porter le le Premier ministre et
vraiment la majorité je
crois est dans cette même écho dans C
même écho alors gabrielal veut
désmicardiser la France mais au fond
est-ce que tous ces bas salaires en
France qui augmentent peu est-ce que
c'est pas le résultat de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 7 ans qui a
préféré les primes à la hausse des
salaires en fait c'est pas tout à fait
ça quand on dit desti disait quand vous
regardez une grille de salaire en
réalité ça coûte très cher pour vraiment
augmenter celui qui est osmic pour
vraiment l'augmenter vous voulez
l'augmenter de 100 € pour son patron en
fait ça va coûter presque 400 €. parce
qu'en fait il y a tellement d'aide et de
défiscalisation des des socialisations
pour au niveau du SMIC que la la grille
de salaire se comprime et donc au fond y
compris dans les avantage euh pour
pour vous ne payez pas d'impôt sur le
revenu vous ne vous avez
des avantages sociaux par exemple pour
les crèches pour les cantines scolaires
vous n'avez plus intérêt quand vous êtes
os SMIC en fait à aller demander une
augmentation et d'ailleurs je je le vois
je le constate et je l'entends il y a y
a il y a beaucoup moins de revendication
pour ceux qui sont au SMIC d'aller
d'aller gagner 20 30 40 € de plus parce
qu'en fait ça leur fait perdre de
l'argent et ça c'est pas comment vous
augmentez ces bas salaires qui sont
juste audessus du SMIC c'est ça que nous
avons nous avons proposé et le Premier
ministre il sait qu' il a une majorité
les députés aiss quit à C on va
travailler dessus trouver les moyens de
faire en sorte de remettre de la
progressivité dans les salaires être
SMIC c'est une entrée c'est une entrée
de quand vous commencez à travailler
vous vous pourriez commencer au SMIC il
faut qu'il y a une évolution de carrière
on porte la valeur travail c'est pas
l'état qui a la main sur sur ses
salaires mais mais le SMIC il est c'est
un un référentiel en disant on commence
au SMIC et on continue il y a une
progression vous vous êtes vous êtes de
mieux en mieux dans votre métier vous
apprenez des compétences et donc
évidemment il doit y avoir une évolution
et comment faire en sorte que quelqu'un
reste motivé dans une entreprise s'il
s'aperçoit qu'en fait quels que soi ses
efforts quelle que soit sa progression
quelle que soit sa formation il reste
scotché au même salaire ce n'est pas
possible il faut qu'on arrive à casser
ce système qui là pour encore une fois
est très administratif de bureaucratique
en fait qui bloque les salaires du côé
donc la solution elle est pas encore
très claire on doit on doit travailler
comme je vous l'ai dit il y a qu'est-ce
qui se passe d'abord il y a le salaire
il y a évidemment l' les les aides de
d'État qui permettent d'accompagner les
primes vous avez raison là-dessus et
puis il y a toutes les aides qui
s'enclenchent parce que vous êtes
osmique et qui se qui ne sont plus là
quand vous vous n'êtes plus au SPIC donc
il faut qu'on arrive à mettre tout sur
la table et qu'on fasse en sorte de de
de trouver la solution pour retrouver
des progressivité dans le dans dans dans
les salaires alors Gabriel Attal veut
aussi poursuivre la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et il a notamment
annoncé que les chômeurs en en fin de
droit qui pouvaient percevoir une une
allocation spécifique jusqu'à alors qui
leur donne droit à des à valider des
trimestres de retraite seront désormais
au RSA est-ce que c'est une manière de
les responsabiliser certains diront de
les culpabiliser il y a deux
philosophies et nous on l'assume très
clairement nous une personne qui est au
chômage on doit faire on doit tout
mettre en œuvre avec France travail avec
les formations de l'accompagnement au
quotidien toutes les semaines où tu en
es comment je peux aider on doit être là
pour l'aider pour retrouver du travail
nous ce que nous voulons pas c'est au
fond dire bah puisqu'on indemnise on
verra bien ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui
quand on regarde ce qui se passe un ceux
qui sont vraiment en grande difficulté
on doit beaucoup plus les accompagner
parce qu'ils ne retrouveront pas du
travail par eux-mêm il faut qu'on les
forme il faut qu'on les accompagne il y
a beaucoup d'accompagnements qui sont
nécessaires ce par contre qui retrouve
très facilement du travail quand on
regarde la courbe quelques quelques
semaines avant la fin de leur droit il y
a une accélération de reprise du travail
donc on voit bien
que c'est pas une question de profiter
c'est il y a un système qui est qui s
appelle assurance chômage et qui pour
une partie de nos concitoyens est devenu
un autre une autre forme de revenu tout
simplement il y a plus d'assurance il y
a un système bah on travaille une partie
du temps et puis ensuite on s'arrête et
on on se remet à travailler ensuite et
donc nous on veut faire en sorte que ce
soit plus difficile de faire parce qu'en
fait not système il tiendra pas on on on
veut baisser les impôts on veut avoir
plus de net on parlait tout à l'heure du
SMIC si s'il y a une partie de la
population qui ne travaille pas il faut
financer ça non seulement ça produit pas
de recher de de de de de richesse mais
en plus ça coûte de l'argent il faut qu'
trou mieux accompagner les demandeurs
d'emploi tout de suite tout de suite et
continuer tout au long mais par contre
ceux qui joue pas le jeu bah il faut que
ce soit plus court l'indemnisation une
question sur la crise agricole Sylvin
Mayer puisque Gabriel Atal a dans ce
dans cette déclaration de politique
générale fait de nouvelles annonces pour
les agriculteurs également toute cette
semaine les blocages ont été
majoritairement levés et dans ces
annonces et bien il y a la mise en pause
du plan écofyo du gouvernement pour
réduire l'usage des pesticides est-ce
que ça veut dire que
l'écologie la qualité alimentaire sont
en train de payer le prix de cette crise
agricole je je crois qu'il faut prendre
un peu de recul cette crise agricole
nous montre une chose un on peut pas
laisser nos agriculteurs dont en même
temps on leur dit il faut absolument
assurer notre souveraineté
d'alimentation être face à des produits
ou ou des des importations qui ne qui
n'ont pas les mêmes normes que les
nôtres moi j'ai très j'ai confiance dans
la ferme France elle est capable elle
elle est capable d'être extrêmement
compétitive elle l' pourquoi pourquoi
arrêter la baisse des PESD mais en fait
ce que ce que nous faisons c'est que
très souvent nous sur nous avons
probablement la surtransposition la plus
forte d'Europe c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
des produits qui sont interdits en
France et qui sont autorisés partout
dans le reste de l'Europe et évidemment
partout dans le reste du monde nous on
dit une chose on s'aligne au niveau
européen il faut que ce qui est décidé
au niveau européen s'applique à
l'ensemble des pays européens et que
nous interdisions l'entrée de produits
de l'extérieur extraeuropéen qui ne
suivent pas nos normes là vous visez le
traité Mercosur qu' que que l'Europe
essz RA parce que Emmanuel Macron vient
de bloquer la ratification de ce ce
traité qui est en cours depuis depuis
très longtemps ça veut dire que vous
macronis qui était plutôt un peu porteur
d'une Europe libérale est devenu
souverainiste non mais moi je suis un
libéral moi je souhaite plus d'échang
mais là onfend la souveraineté française
européenne vous avez raison je souhaite
je souhaite plus d'échanges plus il y a
d'échanges plus il y a de la création de
la richesse dans le monde mais pas avec
le mercosour mais dans dans le mercosour
il y a des choses qui sont bien dans de
ce que propose qui sont intéressantes
mais sur la question agricole et donc
c'est ça qui bloque sur la question
agricole ça ne va pas les produits qui
pourraient arriver en France ne
correspondent pas aux normes que nous
acceptons sur en France et donc nous
disons non non non tant que les normes
ne sont pas les normes européennes de
produits
agricooles pourrait est susceptible de
rentrer en France ce sera non alors le
premier ministre Gabriel Attal a
également détaillé toutes ses mesures au
sénateur mercredi dans une déclaration
et vous allez le voir il n'a pas reçu un
accueil très chaleureux à droite comme à
gauche Mathias
sarz sous la coupole du Palais du
Luxembourg et face à une autre majorité
Gabriel Atal a prononcé une nouvelle
version de son discours de politique
générale pendant 1 heure et demi le
Premier ministre a déroulé son programme
de gouvernement face à des sénateurs
pour certains
dubitatifs l'illusion
macroniste du social libéralisme de 2017
aura duré un printemps vous n'avez fait
que semer les graines de la colère qui
sont en train de germer sur le terreau
de vos choix de société et votre
vocabulaire guerrier n'est que le signe
avant tout d'une grande faiblesse
idéologiquement opposé à Patrick canner
Bruno rotaillo montre lui aussi
l'hostilité de son groupe au chef de
l'exécutif monsieur mais n'attendez pas
de nous que nous devenions macronist
vous dites j'ai confiance nous n'avons
pas confiance nous avons appris à nous
méfier aujourd'hui il faudra que cette
confiance vous puissiez la reconstruire
parce qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment qui
domine ici c'est précisément la défiance
à l'inverse Hervé Marseille chef de fil
de l'autre composante de la majorité
sénatoriale l'Union centriste appel à la
responsabilité de chacun cette
responsabilité elle pèse sur vos épaules
elle pèse aussi sur nos épaules si vous
échouez si nous échouons vous et nous
savons qui arbitrera nos différ en 2027
et alors il sera trop tard pour pleurer
sur le lait renversé un sénat qui ne
fera donc pas plus de cadeau à
gabrielalka Elisabeth born et sans qui
cela a été rappelé la réforme des
retraites et la loi immigration
n'auraient pu être adopté ti Sylvain
Maillard on l' entendu les sénateurs les
républicains n'ont plus confiance dans
le gouvernement ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir été trahis par Emmanuel Macron
sur la loi immigration est-ce que vous
craignez à la fin de l'entente cordiale
avec les LR je sais pas s une entente
cordiale en tout cas on travaille
évidemment avec les sénateurs et et on
continuera à travailler avec les
sénateurs sur immigration moi je j'ai
vécu de l'intérieur les discussions et
les négociations des uns avec les autres
très clairement tout a été mis sur la
table tout a été mis sur la table nous
leur avons dit qu'une partie de des
articles qui proposaient étaient
inconstitutionnel n leur avons dit je
leur ai dit ils le savaient parfaitement
et et donc le Conseil constitutionnel a
fait son travail et a a fait en sorte
que enfin dit en tout cas que 31 article
n'était pas constitutionnel donc je je
je ne comprends pas très bien ce jeu de
ce ce jeu que pourrait jouer leslr il le
savaient c'était leur stratégie il
voulaient démontrer que la loi devait
être la Constitution devait être changée
il nous l'ont toujours dit et donc là ce
pe ce changement de pied je ne comprends
pas très bien si ce n'est peut-être un
une posture en tout cas les sénateurs
centristes veulent réintroduire dans une
proposition de loi certaines des mesures
de de la loi imigration qui avait bien
été voté par vous au Parlement mais qui
ont été retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel notamment le
durcissement du regroupement familial ou
encore de l'accès à certaines
prestations est-ce que vous si ça
revient si ces mesures reviennent vous
serez cohérents et vous voterez ces
mesures retoqué je le dis très
clairement la loi immigration est
derrière nous h nous avons voté des
mesures très fort le cœur de ce que nous
voulions a été voté hein n sur les 27
articles 26 articles on été voté ce que
nous demandent les Français c'est pas
faire des lois après des lois ce qui
nous demande c'est d'être efficace et
faire en sorte que ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à être en France repartent de
France et donc le le travail il est au
niveau du gouvernement maintenant au
niveau de nos administrations au niveau
de nos policiers au niveau de nos
gendarmes de faire en sorte non on na
pas tourné le nous l'avons tourné ici à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez raison
par contre qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut
du résultat il faut faire en sorte que
ça fonctionne c'est ça que nous demande
les Français n demand pas de faire des
lois pour faire des lois il nous demande
que ça fonctionne donc on a un très beau
texte qui vient d'être promulgué et
qu'il faut appliquer maintenant
maintenant il faut l'appliquer et et
l'appliquer tout de suite c'est pas très
cohérent parce que vous les
parlementaire de la majorité
présidentielle vous aviez voté en
décembre un texte de compromis avec les
centristes avec les républicains
certaines mesures ont été retoquées pour
des raisons formel pourquoi ne pas les
les réintroduire je je le redis nous le
cœur de ce que nous
voulions les les articles les plus
importants pour nous he je rappelle
faire en sorte que ceux qu'ont pas
vocation en France s'en aille tout a été
validé et promulgué faire en sorte que
ceux qui travaillent dans les métiers en
tension puissent être régularisés c'est
ce que nous voulions tout a été euh
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
promulgué maintenant on a on a un texte
on doit travailler faire en sorte que ça
s'incarne moi je suis pas là pour faire
de la loi pour de la loi il faut que ça
s'applique je le redis encore les
Français c'est ce qui nous demande le
dernier kilomètre faire en sorte que les
4000 personnes qui n'étaient pas
expulsablebl alors que ce sont des
criminels euh euh avec étranger il faut
qu'il soit expulsé maintenant il y a du
travail à faire et c'est ce travail que
nous demandent les Français nous
demandent pas de faire des lois pour des
lois non mais donc vous dites l'urgence
maintenant c'est d'appliquer cette loi
voter on revient pas en arrière donc pas
de pas de nouveau débat au Parlement sur
l'migration mais du coup l'annonce faite
par Gabriel hatal de décider de réformer
l'ame comme Elizabeth BN s était engagée
lors d'un compromis avec la droite et
bien ça passera par voie règlementaire
ça vous arrange finalement que ce soit
par VO rgl par la loi débat au Parlement
je vous invite à relire la lettre de
d'éliisabeth borne et elle sera tenue
c'est un engagement qui sera tenu
d'ailleurs et qui engage également la
majorité je le dis encore quel est
l'objectif c'est de faire des lois ou de
faire une incarnation d'une politique
qui qui qui existe sur le terrain laame
on peut en discuter l'aide médicale
d'État on peut discuter moi j'ai plein
de choses des propositions regardons ce
qu'a dit stéphanini Evin le rapport vous
savez qui est à la base de la réflexion
il y a des choses qu'on peut améliorer
sur le panier soin sur l'accès aux soins
mais nous on a d'autres propositions moi
je vais vous dire sur sur laame moi je
pense titre personnel qu'il faut qu'elle
soit plus rapide quelqu'un qui arrive
sur notre territoire doit pouvoir
bénéficier de la me par contre en
contrepartie 3 mois voilà mais mais
quand il arrive et c'est c'est à ce
moment-là qu' do il doit être soigné
plus vite par contre peut-être avec un
délai une durée moins longue moins
longue de de d'obtention de de durée de
de la me et parce qu'après vous faut
rentrer dans un parc parcours classique
d'assurance quand on travaille enfin
voilà de de système de sécurité sociale
ça veut dire qu'on s'intègre mais par
exemple le conditionner au fait d'être
vaccinés toutes les vaccins qui sont
obligatoires pour chacun d'entre nous
faire en sorte que ceux qui arrivent sur
notre territoire soient automatiquement
vaccinés voilà moi je trouve que ce
serait une mesure extrêmement efficace
de protection de la personne qui arrive
sur notre territoire et en même temps
montrer qu'on veut rentrer dans la
communauté et qu'on arrive dans les
standards je trouve que ce serait une
une belle évolution alors dans son
discours Gabriel Atal c'est aussi déc et
tout ça c'est réglementaire pas besoin
de loi équ un sujet qui vous concerne
très précisément Sylvain Maillard
puisque le Premier ministre s'est
déclaré favorable à la réforme du
scrutin des élections municipales à
Paris Lyon Marseille c'est vous qui
allez déposer un texte sur ce sujet
d'abord est-ce que ce texte est prêt ce
sera dans quel calendrier est-ce que
vous souhaitez supprimer les mit de
secteur ou les mit d'arrondissement
alors sur cette loi vous savez je je
travaille dessus avec mon collègue David
Amiel qui est député de de Paris nous
travaillons dessus depuis plusieurs mois
c'est un texte évidemment vous SZ
construire une proposition de loi prend
évidemment du temps on a encore
plusieurs auditions à faire l'idée elle
est simple c'est que ce qui est assez
étonnant d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le cas
un Parisien égal une voix un liyonnais
égal une voix un Marseillais égal une
voix c'est comme ça dans toutes les
villes de France sauf dans trois villes
et donc ce qui fait que dans chacune des
villes d'ailleurs dans chaque depuis 40
ans depuis qu'il y a la loi de faire qui
s'applique à partir de 83 dans chacune
des ville il y a un maire ou une maire
qui a été élu sans être majoritaire et
donc nous ça on veut plus deè chose ça
permettra de de faire d'avoir une
circonscription unique de faire en sorte
que le maire ou la merire de chacune des
villes soit le maire ou la mer de tout
le monde pas uniquement de ses cins pour
Paris par exemple on a une mire de Paris
à nidalgo qui est maire de l'Est
parisien elle s'occupe plus de l'Est
parisien parce que ce sont ces maires
d'arrondissementondiss ell s'en occupe
pas très bien mais mais ell s'en occupe
plus que le reste ou elle s'en occupe
pas du tout suprime les M
d'arrondissement sur les méries
d'arrondissement moi je suis très
attaché je pense que c'est vraiment dans
les trois villes ça fait mérite secteur
enfin ça fait partie vraiment de l'ADN
donc oui nous on propose un principe
assez simple de deux urnes il y aura une
une une élection pour les maires
d'arrondissement donc comme dans
n'importe quelle autre ville donc on
pour une les maires d'arrondissement et
l'autre pour le le maire de de Paris de
Lyon de Marseille voilà une liste
conseil municipal une liste conseil
d'arrondissement conseil de seeur mais
au fond Sylvin maer quel est le but de
de cette réforme c'est pour reprendre à
la gauche Paris et dans ce cas est-ce
que vous serez capable de faire une
union
des forces comme la gauche a réussi à le
faire parce
que encore une fois je vous dis
l'objectif c'est pas c'est pas un mode
de scrutin qui vous fait gagner une
élection ou pas qu'est-ce qui change ce
mode de sctin 1 c'est redonner envie au
parisiens au lyonnais au marseillais de
venir voter parce qu'en fait tout est
joué d'avance en fonction des secteurs
ou des arrondissements où vous êtes au
fond c'est déjà qui va gagner donc ça ça
perd l'envie de de de changer de
s'impliquer dans sa ville comme par
hasard ces trois villes perdent du monde
et perd des habitants accélération très
très forte de de 15000 personnes quitent
Paris par exemple par an deuxième chose
c'est une circonscription unique c'estàd
que le maire ou la maire sera obligé de
s'occuper vous devra s'occuper de
l'ensemble de sa ville pas uniquement là
où elle éit on un calendri pour alors je
je le dis on déposera un texte tout
début du printemps pour un examen en
séance ici à l'Assemblée nationale que
je souhaite milieu du printemps et
ensuite on verra avec les sénateurs mais
l'idée c'est que ce soit votter en
première lecture dans les deux chambres
avant les Jeux Olympiques alors on va
terminer avec ce vote très symbolique
cette semaine l'Assemblée nationale a
donné son feu vert à l'inscription dans
la Constitution de la liberté garantie
des femmes de recourir à l'IVG peu après
ce vote solennel la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a tweeté ceci pour
nos filles pour toutes les femmes pour
toujours je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction du ministre qui a apporté le
texte Éric Dupont
Moretti ce
soir l'Assemblée nationale et le
gouvernement
n'ont pas manqué leur rendez-vous avec
l'histoire des
femmes je vais convaincre le Sénat avec
détermination humilité et naturellement
avec tout le respect que l'on doit à
toutes les consciences que cette réforme
est une réforme utile convaincre le
Sénat que c'est une réforme juste je
vais m'atteler à convaincre le Sénat que
cette réforme nous la devons à toutes
les femmes de notre pays convaincre le
Sénat qu'il est grand temps en 2024
d'inscrire dans la Constitution que la
liberté d'avorter pour les femmes est
une liberté fondamentale et que les
femmes peuvent disposer comme elles
l'entendent de leur
corps Sylvain Maillard pour être
définitivement adopté ce projet de loi
constitutionnel qui va inscrire les VG
dans la Constitution doit être voté à
l'identique à la virgule près par
l'Assemblée et par le Sénat or Gérard
Larché président du Sénat et Bruno
rotaillon ont dit un peu leur opposition
claire pour inscrire les VG dans la
Constitution est-ce que vous craignez
tout simplement que cette réforme soit
empêché par le Sénat d'abord vous dire
la fierté qui est la mienne et la fierté
des débutés de mon groupe de d'avoir
voter ce texte vraiment c'est un moment
très fort à l'Assemblée nationale dans
une journée forte hein
juste à la ensite juste à la après le la
déclaration de politique générale mais
un moment extrêmement fort oui nous nous
pensons que c'est fondamental de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution et donc
je crois que la force qui a donné qu'on
donné l'ensemble des groupes politiques
de l'Assemblée national va faire en
sorte que le Sénat ne soit pas bloquant
là-dessus je crois qu'au contraire il
doit être facilitant ça doit être ça
doit nous regrouper on doit aller au
Congrès rapidement et faire en sorte que
ce soit
constitutionnalisé ce sera un signal
extraordinaire ce serait la première
fois dans le monde que un pays
constitutionnalise l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse c'est un message
dingue à l'heure actuelle pardon de le
dire comme ça parce que on est dans un
dans un monde où les droits des femmes
régressent partout partout et donc nous
on enverrait en France le signal ou non
non non c'est pas inéductable au
contraire nous on se bat pour çaou alors
il y aura un débat très précis au Sénat
sur la rédaction de cette révision
constitutionnelle là votre texte prévoit
la liberté garantie de recourir à l'IVG
pour les femmes les sénateurs estiment
que ça revient à mettre le droit
vraiment à l'IVG dans la Constitution il
préfère une rédaction avec le mot
liberté seulement est-ce que vous pouvez
trouver un accord sur ce point c'était
la la discussion que nous avons eu avant
avant le le projet de loi c'est une
proposition de loi donc qui a qui a fait
la navette entre les deux c'est la
proposition des sénateurs moi je pense
que c'est c'est un compromis bien
liberté de liberté garantie je crois que
ce serait vraiment la coconstruction
parfaite entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
national écoutez moi j'ai confiance
confie liberté si c'est juste liberté je
je j'ai confiance on verra ce que
propose le Sénat mais j'ai confiance je
pense qu' les sénateurs ont entendu le
message extrêmement fort de l'Assemblée
l'ensemble des groupes de l'Assemblée
vous vous avez dit même Marine Le Pen a
voté pour donc sil vote les sénateurs
assumeront d'être à la droite de Mar
honnêtement c'est un débat qui est en
dehors de de la politique je je crois
que c'est un débat qui est plus haut que
ça et donc je je souhaite qu'ils
entendent que cette écriture à à
embrasser l'intégralité des groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée nationale ce
qui est quand même pas si fréquent que
ça et donc dans un moment aussi fort
d'unité nationale je pense que le Sénat
doit l'entendre et ça lui donnera
probablement la force de voter une une
écriture conforme et ce sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoupard d'avoir été
notre invité cette semaine merci à tous
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine ciao
[Musique]
ciao
I